okay i think uh the time has come let's
get this show started
so welcome everybody to the first
session of itcs 2021
um this is the session on privacy and
cryptography
um as uh james said so there's five
talks in this session each one will have
eight minutes
um speaking and of course there'll be a
little bit of time switching in between
uh and also as he said things are a
little bit experimental
um so let's see how it goes my my plan
is to set it up so that possibly one
quick question can go after each talk
um but but the majority of the questions
uh save them
until the end and will have an open time
and you can address for each of the
different
authors okay uh
so the first talk in the session is uh
on distributed differential privacy and
counting distinct
elements this is a work also i should
say i saw the names
in this session are going to be quite
the exciting challenge so i apologize in
advance
so this is by lee chen badigasi ravi
kumar
and passin manurangsi
and we will give the talk
oh hi everyone i'm luigi chen from mit
thanks for joining me i have today and
i'm super happy to present my joint work
with buddy robin passing from google
research
so since i've seen the talking sound
differential privacy let us start by
recording the definition
of differential privacy suppose we have
an algorithm m
runs on a data set d consisting of n
elements
x1 to xn and produces a probabilistic
output n of t and we say two they are
sets are neighboring
if they differ by at most one element
and we see an algorithm m is epsilon
delta differentially private
even for all pairs of neighboring
decisions d1 and d2
and r possible invents e the probability
of e
happening under d1 and d2 differ by a
multiplicative factor of
e to the epsilon with a small additive
tolerance delta
this definition is beautiful but it does
not entirely address the concept of
privacy
in the distributed setting in such a
setting each user holds their own data x
i
in initially to naively implement the
above algorithm m
they have to send their raw data x i to
a single curator
and then the curator runs the private
algorithm m on the collected dash of d
the important issue here is that after
sending your raw data to the curator
you have to trust their integrity for
the rest of your life
and sometimes this may not be a good
idea because the tax
the database could be hacked and your
information could be lost
so the local model in a different
privacy is proposed to address the
concern of
that users may not want to trust the
curator
instead of sending their raw data to the
curator
they first apply a randomizer r on their
data
x i and then sends the output of the
randomizer to the curator
and we use the transcript to denote
everything the curator sees with that d
here
in the local model the transcript
is just a concatenation of all the
messages rx1
to rxn and the
curator just runs the algorithm on on
the transcript
the privacy requirement now is that even
the curator
cannot learn anything about a single
user
so in the same spirit we can define the
epsilon delta differential privacy in
the local model
as follows so definition is basically
the same
this looks good but it also comes at a
price
as we'll see later to achieve the same
privacy
algorithms in local models sometimes
perform much worse than their
counterparts in the central model
so motivated by the drawback of the
local model and
the central model the subtle model aims
to provide
better utility while putting as little
trust as possible on the curator
this model is an additional layer of a
shuffle
which applies a random permutation on
all the messages sent by the user
and the curator runs on the shuffled
version on
all the messages without knowing which
user sends which messages
so in other words it anonymize other
messages
again we define the transcript with data
id as
everything the curator sees in a
protocol
here the transcript is the output of the
leveler
which is that random permutation of all
the messages
rxis and the curator runs on the
transcript
similarly we can define the epsilon
delta differential
privacy in the shelter model as well
we note that similar to the local model
here we put no trust in the curator but
we do put additional trust in the
shuffle
by assuming it correctly performs the
random permutation
therefore the privacy can can go through
so to compare these models a great
example is the basic
aggregation problem where each user gets
a single boolean bit
and the goal is to estimate the sum
with constant epsilon polynomial
differential privacy constraint
as one can see we have a spectrum of
trust in the curator
another spectrum of of the utility
here is the arrow and the great thing
about shuttle model is that for this
basic problem you can achieve
constant error by only putting
additional trust in the sharper
therefore it cannot achieve the best of
both worlds for the next problem
and i think this talk will study the
problem called
current distinct problem which is
another basic problem in the distributed
setting
so their end users each has their own
data x i and the goal is to estimate the
number of distinct elements among x1 to
xn
under the constraint of being epsilon
delta dp
in the central model the problem is very
easy and you can achieve constant error
and we first show that not only for
constant episode epsilon
in fact for some d equals n by
poly log n for link d epsilon the
problem is still
nearly maximally hard as is required and
by pulling locking arrow in the local
model
and surprisingly we further ask you we
further increase epsilon from link d
to link n and the problem suddenly
becomes very easy
it can be solved with arrow root n
comparing to
nearly n note that being d equals
mean n minus or log log n so it is very
close to the
n and for the shuffle model we first
show that for constant epsilon and the
inverse quasi-polynomial delta
cognitive thing is nearly maximally hard
for the single message shuttle model
in which everyone can send at most one
messages
and next surprisingly we should if we
allow each user to send at the most
half-past om messages in expectation
instead of being worst case the problem
can be solved by cyber protocol
with square root and arrow that that's
therefore there is a big gap between
messages in worst case
and the messages in expectation and note
that the current distinct problem has
global sensitivity 1.
so already large implies are 1 versus
near linear separation between
global sensitivity and aero in local and
shuffle model
it's the answer's an open question we
also obtain a one versus
neo-linear separation between global
sensitivity and error in two-party
differential privacy and answer another
open question
and check the paper for more details on
this part and finally
we obtain some new lower bonds for other
problems in the cellphone model
the selection problem is defined as
follows so there are end users
the ice one gets a three-dimensional
preference vector
and the for for f in for index j
the square of j is defined as the
expectation of x i j
and the goal is to find out j star such
that the square of j star is close to
maximum
and we select const for constant
constant epsilon
1 over n delta differential private
shuffle protocol with at the most k
messages for each user can node cannot
solve selection if
n is at most d by k
our result is similar to our recent
independent work by children almond
they study a more restricted version of
shuffle model called the robust shuffle
model
and they prove that for unbounded
messages which use like
function user such models still cannot
solve selection of ants at most duty
so let's conclude with some open
problems so the first question can we
prove a lower bounds for unbounded
messages in the shadow model
without a robustness constraint as you
can see the other balance requires a
robustness condition
where all opens does not work for
unbounded messages case
and also can we extend a single message
level about the full count distinct
region of delta equals bible polynomial
all lower bound requires delta equals
one over quasi polynomial so that's an
open question
thank you that's all
okay thank you very much
and so actually perfect timing on the
top
excellent so uh let's take a quick
question well the next speaker
is setting up so celia
um hi hi lee uh can you say anything
about the
techniques in the lower bounds and in
particular do you identify
a hard distribution of um inputs for
for these problems for the distinct
count distinct problem
yes so actually that the lower bounds we
use the
so we use the the lower bound techniques
for proving the open of the
estimate the unseen problem in the in
the literature
of for property testing so here we use
something called moment matching
so we would construct two two random
variables with matched moments
but
rival is mostly zero and one variable is
mostly non-zero
and then we use two these two random
variables to construct two very
different
distribution they they behave
similarly their moments behave similarly
but somehow the number of distinct
elements
differ dramatically and then we show
that
uh uh local local algorithm cannot
distinguish this
based on some personalization trick i
mean it's a
high however idea the the weapon itself
is pretty complicated
yeah great thanks thanks for the
question
all right perfect um so nikita go ahead
and clean the stage here
oh sorry could you stop is you're
showing sorry i
can okay sorry
okay excellent uh so in a second so the
second talk will be
on basing auxiliary input cryptography
on np hardness
via non-adaptive black box reductions
this is worked by makito
nanashima and indeed he will be giving a
talk
yeah thank you so okay my name is mikhna
shima so
yeah today i'm going to talk about talk
about this topic okay let's begin with
the introduction
so this work is related to these two
fields
worst case hardness in complexity and
cryptography and as you know there's a
huge gap between these two fields
and one of the most challenging question
is to construct one wave functions
based on the hardness of np problems in
other words to show this direction
so and very natural approach is very
basic
approach to show this direction is to
construct a reduction from
solving some language l to inverting
some function f
and if this l is np hard problem then we
can show the control positions
above result but to construct
such a reduction and there's a specific
barrier on the types of reduction
that is no adaptive block box reduction
so and so
in this setting this type of reduction
looks like this figure
and the key part is so yeah
this reduction accesses adversary for
inverting f
as a black box as a oracle and it makes
its queries parallel or in one round
and this is a very simple and familiar
form of
reductions but unfortunately the
previous work showed that
if we can get such a simple reduction
for this problem
then we can show this result
and the point is that so if there is np
heart problem then this impulse crops or
polynomial hierarchy
in other words under the very reasonable
assumption on polynomial hierarchy we
can exclude such an
attempt and this previous work
gives us very important directions
developing
non-black box techniques or adaptive
techniques
but in general to construct such a
somewhat complicated techniques uh
seems to be very challenging task
especially for this program
so that's why in this work we try to
suggest the third choice
that is to change the goal
or in other words we try to get
intermediate cryptographic primitive
instead of standard cryptography
and our focus of this work is auxiliary
in
cryptographic primitives which was
originally introduced by ostrovsky and
big dawson
and this type of primitive is not one
specific
function but defined as a formula
function
indexed by a binary strings and which
has a
vertical security condition that for
each polynomial
adversary so depending uh on this a
adversary there exists a secure part for
whole adversary
and this is the natural intermediate
model between usual worst case hardness
and
average case cryptography and breaking
such a
usually cryptographic prim dips can be
formatted as a kind of
worst case of average case problem
that's why
yeah we cannot apply a directory the
previous work on non-adaptive black box
worst case
average case reduction to this case
so the important question
is if we try to get such intermediate
cryptographic primitives
then are no adaptive block reductions
sufficient
and we address this issue in this work
as a first say for
such a study on intermediate primitives
okay now let's see our result again our
goal is to consider the following
question if we have
some knowledge black box security
rejection from here to
a primitive breaking a primitives then
what happens
and in this work we consider three
fundamental types of a primitive
pseudo-random generator more function
and heating's
generator and lovely speaking the
relation among them
is like this and so the first result is
the following
so if we can get an adaptive block box
security reduction from here to
breaking auxiliary and pseudo random
generator then we can also show the
collapse of polynomial hierarchy
so that's why we can exclude this part
and we also consider these
two cases of uh here input function
obviously
in and the reason why we consider these
two cases separately
is yeah as far as i know the currently
known
security security reduction from the
second primitive to
uh first primitive uses some adaptive
techniques so we cannot translate this
type of black box reaction into the
first one so we
consider these two these two cases
separately
and the second and third result is the
following so if we can get an adaptive
black box reduction
then in fact we cannot show the strong
consequences like the kind of corpse
polynomial hierarchy but we can still
surprising consequences
so we can extend this an adaptive block
box reduction
to one function which has infinitely
often security
via adaptive no adaptive black box
reduction
in others we can get np-based one-way
function
and in fact this is not strong to
exclude such an adaptive black box
reduction
and it has two opposite interpretations
so negatively speaking this can be
regarded as a hardness result for
getting such a
uh no adaptive block box reductions but
positively speaking this can be also
regarded as a new approach for a
np-based one-way function because the
causal runway function
all we have to do is to construct a
primitive be a very
simple security reaction and that's why
so
i guess the important question which
direction
is to verify the validity of this
positive perspective
and i will share with you more two
directions the first one is
consider other cases where such
intermediate primitives or intermediate
primitives can be helpful for
constructing np-based one-way function
second direction is yeah of course there
is a still possibility that uh
this non-adaptive black box reduction
impress corrupts the polynomial
hierarchy that's why the
second direction is to exclude such an
adaptive block box reduction
especially for the case of a sorry
auxiliary
one-way function okay finally let's see
a proof ideas very roughly and this is a
very rough map
for the proof and for the first result
the key part is to
show this part another black box
reduction from here to
some average case problem then we can
get an adaptive block box
worst case to average case reduction
then
by applying the previous work we can
show the collapse of polynomial
hierarchy
and in fact this reduction is also very
simple reaction
and the proof for the second result here
is
i guess the key part of this work so
roughly speaking first we
translate one way function into
auxiliary
pseudorandom genetics by using the
standard cryptographic technique
then we apply this non-adaptive block
box reduction
in assumption again here
then we can construct adaptive block box
reduction from
the employee language to yeah breaking
io1 function so this is very rough
explanation and for the third result we
applied
the universal expression technique to
translate this
type of know about non-adaptive black
box reduction into
non-adaptive black box reaction from nph
language to
breaking auxiliary into our function
then we can apply the second result
again and we have uh
adaptive block box reduction from uh nph
language to breaking wave function
that's where we can
get the start result okay
that's all thank you for your attention
um actually just a quick question while
the next speaker is setting up so maybe
you can
close the share so the next
no problem uh what is it can you
describe a little bit what is the dist
np
ah sorry uh this means a distributional
np problem so
yeah it is a np problem but the instance
is generated according to some
fixed for sample distribution
got it thanks
uh uh if you have time for um
one more query sorry go for it
yeah uh yeah uh i would like to ask
what were the uh uh random
number on genetic algorithms
uh that you used and why were it
uh not uh uh
um feasible in your
setup so sorry could you say
again sir i could not understand yeah uh
uh with respect to the uh
pseudo number uh generations
uh why were it not uh feasible
ah why
but why was it not feasible
because you said no in in your graph
that you do
uh you had uh if you go back
to the slides uh i i think the question
is about
that it's adaptive that the
constructions of prg from one way
functions are adaptive so
impossibility result didn't extend i
think that's the question
yes yes sorry could you say it okay
sorry
sorry uh i think he's asking you had an
impossibility result
about uh prg
and yeah and you said it doesn't extend
um
you had three boxes and he's asking why
didn't it extend
because because it's adaptive
yes yes yes yes so
no um yeah so were there any you bounces
so yeah so you mean sorry uh
so for the secondary that for original
function here it can be a
translated uh blackbox rejection from
breaking a
[Music]
that is your question yes and um
yes yeah that's right so because
as far as all known
security reduction from breaking
auxiliary into our function to
breaking ocean and pseudonymogenes they
use adaptive dignity we do not know
no adaptive ones that's why if we
translate
non-adaptive black box reduction from
language l to
breaking a aion function into
yeah sorry uh breaking a
pseudo-random genetic then we lose the
no adaptiveness that's why we cannot
apply
okay okay yeah yeah yeah okay so if we
can get a
very simple security reduction from uh
example one function to uh
auxiliary then we can also exclude the
attempt for auxiliary function and
object heating situation
um so it's not easily extendable yeah
okay thanks thank you
actually in the meantime we're having
some technical difficulties here and
let's see if we can get this fixed
can you hear me
yes we can hear you okay maybe i will
try sharing again
there was some issue yeah go ahead and
try it says
my screen sharing is paused but can you
see
my screen it just says that you have
started
sharing your screen oh okay i'm clicking
on resume
share and nothing is happening
are you sharing your desktop or just the
application
just the application would you mind
sharing your desktop and then opening
the application within that
okay sure yeah
um so and like i don't okay entire
screen
right yeah
is that okay great no no it's fine right
yes we just need excellent the uh
presentation mode and then
okay great great okay maybe i'll start
good success okay okay so the the next
talk will be on query complexity lower
bounds for local list decoding and
hardcore predicates
there's a work by nova runsville ronan
shaltiel
and nitin varma and nitin will be giving
the talk
hi i'm nitin verma i'm a postdoc at
university of haifa and i'll be talking
about query complexity lower bounds for
local list decoding and hardcore
predicates
i'll first briefly define list decoding
localized decoding
and briefly tell you about our results
and applications of our results to black
box proofs for
hardcore predicates i will conclude with
some open problems
a binary code is half minus epsilon l
less decodable
if for every word w
there are at most l messages whose
encodings
are close to w in the sense that the
distance between the encodings of these
messages and w
is at most half minus epsilon times n or
in other words
for every word there are only very few
code words in the code that are close to
it
now list decoding has a lot of
applications in theory cs
and this has also been generalized
to sub linear time uh algorithms as
local is decoding
and the goal here is to recover each
coordinate of a
desired message from the list locally in
sub linear time
and a more formal definition is like
this for every word
and every message m such that the
encoding of this message
is close to the word so you want to
basically when you're given query access
to the word
you there exists some advice that your
algorithm gets
such that for every message coordinate
you output the bit cut off the desired
message
of at that coordinate with probability
at least two thirds
and we study local list decoding
of very low rate codes a candidate
example is the hadamard code
and hadamard code has very efficient
local list recorders
a seminal result by goldberg and levin
gives
local list decoders with list size and
query complexity
one over epsilon square for the hadamard
code
and the question that we ask is whether
the query complexity can be improved say
one over epsilon to the little of one
if we allow for very large lists
now the motivation comes from the fact
that improving this upper bound has the
potential
to obtain uh better hardcore predicates
based out of hard one-day functions now
here are results for large epsilon
we show that the query complexity of
local lens decoding is
1 over epsilon square omega and this is
a tight lower bound as evidenced by the
upper bound by goldberg 11
and our lower bound holds for
large list sizes and in particular also
for
codes of very low rate okay so for codes
for very low rate
this is also the first lower bound even
for small list sizes
and our result extends and improves the
result of
greenberg guitar that worked for codes
with larger rate
in particular the result of greenberg
guitar did not apply for hadamard
and for smaller epsilon we show a lower
bound of
omega root of one over epsilon and
together
these rule out the upper bound of one
over epsilon to the little of one
and even for very large lists and
here are some consequences of our
results um so
goal track 11 theorem can be restated in
terms of
obtaining hardcore predicates suppose
you have a
very hard one-way function that for
circuits of
of size s it is hard to invert the
function
f with probability more than um rho
now based on this f you can define a new
runway function f
new and a predicate f thread such
that for all circuits c prime of size
s prime which is only smaller than s by
a factor q where q is the query
complexity of hadamard
locally recording hadamard you can
say that like for a random input
if you only have access to the
evaluation
of fnu on this random input your circuit
cannot compute the evaluation of f
thread the predicate on this random
input with advantage of
more that of more than epsilon over
random guessing
now concretely assume you have a circuit
um you have a heart function that cannot
be inverted by
circuits of polysize with probability
one over polykey
then goldrich levin assures that you can
get
obtain a hardcore predicate with
uh that cannot be guessed with an
advantage of more than of
less than one overpoly key now
uh even if the original function you
start with
has a much stronger hardness this is all
that gold right 11 can give you
and the first question
we ask based out of these results is
whether it is possible to
obtain a much stronger hardcore
predicate
maybe by replacing hadamard with another
locally listed codable code
and so we proved that no it is not
possible
and the proof is an extension of the
proof for the small epsilon case
now we also ask something much more
general
so we ask whether maybe it is possible
to obtain
a hardcore predicate a stronger hardcore
predicate
via some completely different black box
kind of method
and we again show that um no so we
define a general class of black box
methods for obtaining hardcore
predicates
and show that uh no so you cannot really
um get very strong hardcore predicates
by black box methods
and here are a bunch of open problems so
one would be to improve the lower bound
for the small epsilon case
uh from one over root epsilon to one
over epsilon square the tight lower
bound
now our lower bound for the large
epsilon case
can be extended to decode from
one minus epsilon fraction erasures and
not errors
erasures to get a pound of one over
epsilon is it possible to do a similar
extension for the small
epsilon case so far we don't see how our
techniques would directly extend but
is it possible now
so we only ruled out black box
techniques for obtaining
stronger hardcore predicates from heart
functions
but maybe there are non black box
techniques that can
help obtain stronger hardcore predicates
from heart functions
and can we do something here
and thank you
[Applause]
thank you um all right is there any
quick question while we move to the next
talk
actually if not then then i have a quick
question um so
when you say a black box this is black
box and what and can you say very
very briefly uh about what kind of
more general form of black box
reductions you guys prove things about
yeah so um in the sense so
so we say that so a black box reduction
can be thought of as a
pair construction and reduction so
construction will
map a heart function to to like
to a new quantity function and also a
predicate
and we do not assume that this map
construction is efficiently computable
or anything and the reduction
uh so gets oracle access
to my heart function and also
some other function h that
claims to invert my heart function
efficiently
right and and additionally the reduction
can also be non-uniform
so it can also get some advice that
depends on both the heart function
and also uh the inverter
in a sense right uh yeah so this is the
general
generic uh setup i don't think i missed
out anything but yeah
more or less but of course there are
more details there yeah good
thanks all right thanks um so um
see you guys in the next speaker can
send up
excellent the next talk will be on lower
bounds for off-chain protocols
exploring the limits of plasma this is a
work by
stefan jandowski gregor fabianski
yes so can you hear me
yes
no yes we can hear you yeah okay perfect
yes
sorry so uh hello everyone
uh my name is siamesh and today i will
present the paper lower bounds for off
chain
protocols exploring the limits of plasma
this is a joint work with steven
jimbowski gregos fabianski
sebastian faust and me siavashiri stefan
and gregos are from university of
versailles in poland
and sebastian and i are from tiodam chad
in germany
so let's start with some motivation
we as humans need to maintain ledgers or
logbooks for many different applications
such as trading legal agreements banking
and so on
and traditionally trusted entities such
as the stock market notaries
or banks maintain these log books or
letters for us
however recent events have shown that
these trusted entities are not really
trustworthy
for example there's a scandal regarding
a company called wirecard in germany
stock market
or we all remember uh the 2008 housing
crisis which interrupted the global
markets quite substantially and people
have been thinking well how can we make
these trusted entities behave honestly
well some say that we can achieve this
by more transparency
such that we can detect malicious
behavior sooner
but others have been trying to get rid
of this trusted entity altogether
and one of the proposals to do so is
blockchain technology
and i want to point out that there's a
huge realistic and sometimes
unrealistic hype around blockchain and
technologies related to blockchain
and this work also tries to make the
expectations from protocols run over the
blockchain to become more realistic
but what is blockchain well blockchain's
core
is basically consensus algorithm which
is run between a set of parties and as
long as more than half of the parties
participating in this consensus
algorithm or honest
they can agree on the latest state of
the system however
consensus algorithms large-scale
consensus algorithms are expensive
and that's one of the reasons why
blockchain technologies do not scale for
example bitcoin can process around
10 transactions per second but visa
payment system can process up to 50 000
transactions per second
this is a quite a huge gap here and
people
have been thinking and proposing
solutions in order to
improve blockchain scalability and one
of the more
recent proposals and also the focus of
this work
is offshoring protocols um and by off
chain
i mean that parties only communicate
with the blockchain
if it is necessary and they try to keep
their communication with the blockchain
to a minimum more specifically
we analyze a class of offshoring
protocols called plasma protocols
so what is plasma well
plasma was first introduced by pune and
buterin in 2017
and in the literature it is also
referred to as commit chain
the main idea of plasma is as follows we
have an operator
and parties instead of communicating
with a blockchain and submitting the
transaction to the blockchain they
submitted to this operator who gathers
these transactions
and he periodically times up the latest
state of the system
on the blockchain more specifically
the operator is basically maintaining
his own ledger l
he publishes the content of l offchain
for example on his web page
and periodically timestamps
this this ledger l by publishing the
hash of
l on the blockchain by using this hash
of l parties can later refer to it and
then prove that oh they own some amount
of coins in the system
so as you can see here we are trying to
minimize the communication with the
blockchain so it's an off chain protocol
let me continue with an example assume
that l
i is the latest state of the system
where alice owns one coin bob coins zero
coins and charlie owns one coin
the operator uses the hash function to
stay to hash this table
and publishes just a hash over the
blockchain this idea can further be
improved using miracle trees but i will
i will ignore that
uh for the purpose of this talk so the
total balance of the system at this
point is two
now alice can send one coin for example
to bob and the state would be updated as
follows bob will have
one coin alice would have zero coin and
charlie will have one and this can go on
now this idea can also be extended in
order to allow deposit and withdrawing
assets directly to and from the
blockchain to this plasma system using
the monetary capabilities of the
blockchain
but this solution has a drawback
and the drawback is as follows the
operator can always
withhold this state and not publish it
to the users
this is called the data and availability
attack and i will get back to this more
in a few seconds all in all
there are two main categories of plasma
protocols
one is plasma cache where users own
tokens similar to a cache so we are
assigning tokens to users
and another version of plasma is
fungible plasma where
users have accounts similar to checking
accounts and we are assigning balances
to users
in this system now our contribution
is as follows we show
that there is no perfect plasma protocol
out there
more specifically we show that either
protocols fall under a situation like
plasma cache
where exiting assets from the plasma
system to the blockchain
requires huge communication with the
blockchain or
we are in a situation like fungible
plasma where
the system suffers from a phenomenon
called
non-uniquely attributable mass exits
and we cannot achieve the best of both
worlds now what is your
non-uniquely attributable mass exits by
non-uniquely attributable i mean that
no judge can decide who is malicious the
accuser or the accused
and this directly relates to the data
and availability attack because
data and availability has non-uniquely
attributable
faults although i will not really go
into the details here in this
uh short talk and what is mass exit
methods this means that
honest users must withdraw their assets
before it is too late otherwise they
might lose all their coins
and this is quite substantial because if
everyone tries to exit their
their coins at once then the blockchain
would be overloaded and again they have
to communicate a lot with the blockchain
so i would refer you to the full
presentation
and our paper for more details uh
regarding how our proof works our
modeling works
but here i would like to give a sneak
peek
on the main idea behind
our proof and
our result so i will continue with our
previous example
alice uh has transferred one coin to bob
and now at this point the operator
withholds this latest state l i plus one
from charlie who is the honest party
here
at the same time alice reverts her state
internally
to what it was in ally so she will claim
that she has one coin and she has never
made a transfer to bob
note that charlie is completely unaware
of what has happened between alice and
bob in this state
now bob tries to exit from the system
this is completely legal exits
he owns actually one coin in the system
he should be able to withdraw it
after this exit the total balance of
the plasma system would be reduced by
one so the total bias would be one
because
bob has exited one coin so we would
end up in the following situation
alice claimed that she has one coin
charlie has one coin indeed and bob is
gone
but there is only one coin in the system
so what would happen
if alice exits well charlie
then would not be able to exit his coin
because there is not enough balance left
to assist
how can we prevent alice from exiting
well
either it must be clear from bob's exit
that alice cannot exit this means that
pause exit must contain enough
information in it
that you can under identify people who
have actually transferred
coins to bob so bob's exit would be
large
and the other situation would be that
charlie
must exit before alice so we would end
up in this
mass exit situation which i uh pointed
out before
now this is just just just the main idea
behind our results
uh and uh there are a lot of videos that
i've
just ignored here but for those i would
refer you to the paper and also the long
version of the presentation
so with this i would like to conclude in
this work
we for the first time initiated the
study of lower bounds for off-chain
protocols
and we show that there is an inherent
separation between plasma cash and
fungible plasma so you cannot achieve
the best of
both worlds which were the focus uh for
many years for
many of the people working in this area
and both plasma variants have their
place
and use case in practice so if you have
an
operator who is probably semi trusted
then fungible plasma is the way to go
because it would be much cheaper if
parties want to exit but on the other
hand if the operator is not trusted well
maybe plasma cash would be better
now let me point out some future works
well we just initiated the study of
analyzing lower bounds for off-chain
protocols and there are many different
classes of protocols that can be
analyzed here
channel channel networks virtual
channels and so on
furthermore one can try to improve our
results or try to analyze them by
trying to remove some of the modeling
assumptions that we that
we make or trying to see if the results
would go through
if the modeling is different with this
i would like to thank you all for your
attention and if you have any questions
feel free to ask contact me or any of
the co-authors
thank you very much
[Music]
uh just the uh uh complexity bounce
uh with respect to those new
operations that you have uh uh
introduced uh
does that have a uh effect
on the versus the
vanilla chains oh i'm not sure exactly
what you mean by the operations that we
introduce you mean the depositing and
exiting or
yes uh the uh three uh the um
depositing exiting and uh one more
of operation that you had with respect
to the chaining uh
so basically a plasma protocol must have
all of these operations deposit
exiting and making transfers of chain
because otherwise if you can't deposit
and withdraw assets
you're basically timestamping some
information on the blockchain so it is
not
really that useful so our lower bound
indeed
is regarding the com communication
complexity required with a blockchain
in order to allow users to exit their
assets
from off chain to unchain and being able
to use
okay cool thanks no problem
all right um we'll move now to the final
talk in the session
which is about black box uselessness uh
composing separations in cryptography
this is a joint work between jafar koto
pojef rashim
and muhammad makhmuri and jafar will
give
the presentation yeah thanks a lot
everyone can hear me well good
uh so i'm joffrey this is a joint work
with puya and muhammad
and in this work we try to take a fresh
look
at the notion of black box reductions
that you've heard about
already quite a few times in this
session so
let me briefly recall the basics
um we're looking at cryptographic
reductions so that's an area of
cryptography where we try to prove
statements of the form
if primitive a exists then primitive b
exists
and that's very useful because at their
core
essentially all or most of our
cryptographic primitives rely on
unproven assumptions
like assuming p naught equal to np so uh
proving such reduction simplifies the
crypto landscapes
and allows us to derive new connections
between primitives and to achieve new
construction
constructions so reduction-based
cryptography enjoyed many celebrated
successes in the past for example in the
area of private key cryptography
um a sequence of celebrated results in
the 1990s
have managed to show that essentially
all private key crypto primitives
are equivalent so stream ciphers
universal hash functions commitment
scheme they can all be reduced to the
existence of one-way functions
the most basic object of cryptography
however there are countless cases where
we do not know of such
reductions and that's typically the case
when we try to base the existence of
publicly cryptography
for example on private cryptography so
can we construct key agreement out of
runway functions
we don't know and that's a bit
unfortunate and annoying
because uh we believe key agreement
exists we believe one way function
exists
so there has to be a reduction and the
reduction could be well ignore the
one-way function and build the agreement
from scratch
so this lack of reduction has to be a
limitation of our techniques
so the core inside in this area was
given by empagliatsu and radish
in 1989 and it's the following
most cryptographic reduction that we
know of are black box
in the sense that they are oblivious to
the specific implementation of the
source primitive
and of the adversary so the slightly
more formal
definition is that there is a black box
reduction from a primitive b
to a primitive a if we have a
construction and a reduction
and the construction should be such that
it's a construction of b
which should be efficient whenever we
have an efficient
implementation of the primitive a and
secure
uh whenever we have a secure
implementation as a primitive b in the
sense that we'll have a reduction from
having an adversary against one
to having an adversary against the other
so but let's just stick with black box
reduction are
a large set of techniques for reduction
that do not precisely look
at the in at much more than the input
output behavior
um of the primitives involved and so the
similar result by impagliet so in radish
was that there is no black box
reductions from key agreement to one-way
functions
and since in seminar this similar result
there has been a tremendous number of
black box separation between
cryptographic primitives
and they explain why we've been stuck
for so long at
some problems we're trying to solve but
they also guide
future constructions by running out a
large class of methods
however there are still some limitations
of our black box separation results
and one of them is that a black box
separation
on say between a primitive a and a
target primitive p
only rules out the possibility of
constructing p
from a in a black box way but using a in
isolation
with nothing else out there so in
particular
uh it does not say anything about the
possibility that we could build p
in a black box way uh from two
primitives a and b
even if a alone or b alone are black box
separated from p
so in a sense we do not have any way to
compose our black box impossibility
results to derive
stronger black box compressibility
results and that's unfortunate because
in crypto we do that all the time we
take a bunch of cryptographic primitives
and assumptions
we can sort of mix them together and we
obtain new cryptographic primitives
and who if we want to prove limitations
for black box construction of these
types
then currently the only thing we know
how to do is
say proving black box separation for all
subsets of the cryptographic primitives
that we might want to consider
so can we do better well in our work
what we do is exactly try to introduce a
notion that allows to have this
composition and we call it black box
uselessness
informally a primitive a is black box
useless
for building another primitive p
if for any auxiliary primitive z
if we have a black box construction of p
from a together with z
then we must already have a black box
construction of p from z alone
if we have a black boss uselessness and
we have a natural and easy composition
composition theorem which says that if i
a is black box useless for p and b is
black box useless for p
then the joint primitive a b has to be
black box useless for p
as well why because since a is black box
useless
for p if we have a construction from a b
z we can remove a
seeing b z as the actual primitive z
prime and then we can apply the black
box uselessness of b
to remove b which proves the black box
uselessness of the joint primitive
so that's easy so in our work
the main contributions are four-fold
first a definitional framework
we introduce this notion of black box
uselessness
identify various flavors we cast them in
the framework of black box reduction
uh so the by a ringgold trevizan and
vadan
and we formally proved this uh
composability crm that i
briefly mentioned on the previous slide
and we also um show that a large class
of black box separation methods that
have been used in the past which is
called the compiling out paradigm
satisfies an interesting property in
general which is that
this compiling out techniques still
works even in the presence
of an auxiliary oracle z so in a certain
sense it relativizes
and this means that we can directly
turns uh results
in this framework into blackbox
uselessnessresult
so we get kind of for free a large
number of black box useless results
by importing a result from the
literature
then we look at what's probably the most
fundamental question we could ask in
this area
which is whether a one-way functions are
black box useless for key agreement
or whether we could use them in a black
box way to build key agreement together
with other primitives
and we prove the following preliminary
results um one-way functions
are black box useless in any unbalanced
construction of key agreement
which are all construction of key
agreements where one of the parties
makes only a constant number of queries
to the one-way functions
we also prove a number of related
results for restricted
cases and finally we also look at the
uh complementary landscape of black box
helpful helpfulness
um and plot force a conjecture uh
regarding the black box helpfulness
of one-way functions for building
collision rays and hash functions
but i won't have time to tell more about
it
so before i leave you just a quick
glimpse on uh kind of the main
question we look at which is whether
one-way functions are black boxes less
for building key agreements
so we start from the impact let's radish
black box separation between one-way
function and key agreement
we observed as this attack so it's an
attack against any key agreement that
builds on one-way functions in the black
box way
this attack fails in the presence of an
actuary oracle
however the crucial idea is that we can
make the following case distinction
either one-way functions exist relative
to this auxiliary oracle z
then that means that we can build our
one-way function from z in the first
place so we don't need the one-way
function in our black box construction
and the already implies a key agreement
or there are no
one-way functions relative to z so we
have a one-way function inverter
and we managed to use as this one-way
function inverter
to make the impact zohodish attack
efficient even in the presence of z
up of course to some caveats i'll let
you see in the papers
and so that's the essence of the proof
there are a bunch of open questions that
stem from our work
one of the main one is can we extend our
results to all key agreement protocols
we construct sure that the answer is yes
but we couldn't approve it
and that concludes my talks thank you
for your attention and i'll be happy to
answer an equation
i have a quick question can you tell me
which type of key agreement this doesn't
work for
like what is balanced or unbalanced i
didn't get it yeah so
uh balanced and balanced agreement means
one of the parties will only make a
constant number of queries to the
one-way function
in the protocol so it only makes a very
small
like restricted use of the one-way
function both party can make an
arbitrary number of calls
to the auxiliary primitive z um
so that's so in particular if both
parties only can't
um call the one-way function constant
number of times your separation works
yes you're not separation you're a
result that it's useless
works yes exactly uh but so
but the dream result would be that both
parties can query the one-way function
arbitrary many times
and in this setting we only managed to
rule out miracle-type key agreements
which is where essentially everything is
simultaneous we send a single message
we start making queries and we do not
make queries when computing the output
after receiving the other party message
so this miracle type
key agreement there we can rule out uh
key agreements even with an arbitrary
number of queries
but there were imposing restrictions on
the structure
got it thank you um but does that that
rule out
uh traditional public key cryptography
um so no it does not rule out
traditional uh public
cryptography uh otherwise uh we might
have been more cautious with
stating our results um so no i mean
um
does not make the black box use of a
one-way function it's a direct
construction
so it's a direct construction from a
specific number of theoretic problems so
traditional public key cryptographic i'm
sorry
and then if the if this grievant
protocol
is based on a on a public key
encryption function so rule out a
reduction that uses a one-way function
and another primitive to construct a
public key encryption
oh um so oh sorry yes um
we do rule out uh so you can
so what we were at um construction of
key agreements so this key agreement
uh they have restrictions so if you
extend that to the setting of public key
encryption what we rule out is
the construction of public encryption
that will not make query to the one-way
function
when invoking the decryption or the
decryption function
so we rule out the possibility of having
public encryption that makes
any queries in the encryption but no
queries to the one-way functions
in the decryption but possible queries
to the other primitive
or uh where the encryption would only
make
one of the encryption or decryption
would only make a constant number of
queries
this is the kind of thing that will rule
out
does that answer your question yes thank
you
wait doesn't the second thing like the
first thing was
zero calls to the one-way function and
the decryption and the second thing was
constant in one of them
isn't doesn't that imply isn't
the first case a special case of the
second i realized that
uh at the same time as saying it so uh
if i get
so there is also key generation there is
also key generation so when we say one
party asks the constant number of
queries
key generation and decryption happen by
the same side
got it but if both key generation and
encryption is not constant it's still
good and as long as decryption is zero
yes yes got it thank you
thank you okay just just a moment before
other people jump in uh so at this time
the the next session is we is it will be
starting in about a minute so if you
really wanted
to go to those talks uh feel free go
ahead to the second zoom link
however we are able to stick around uh
and i'd like to
open them the
floor i suppose to questions to any of
the authors so
uh let's go ahead maybe if it becomes
chaotic and you can use your zoom
hand raising
so i wanted to ask you about the last
talk uh uh possible so if i i don't know
if
gfro maybe can can put the slides for
collision resistant hashing
uh do you have uh an assumption which is
maybe unnatural but easy to state
which you think is black box separated
from collision resistance
but with one way function you know is
sufficient
right uh so okay for
a collision recent hash function um
we don't have a we only have a
conjecture but our conjecture is that
they are useful for
um for building question rates and hash
functions and intuitively
uh the auxiliary primitive is um
the simon oracle so the id is the
following simon oracle
so this very weird kind of one-way
permutation but where you can
sample collisions uh alone it does not
give you
a a collision resistance hash function
actually can you can you explain again
what is this thing
yeah so what we want to show is that one
way functions
are helpful for building in a black box
way collision isn't hash function
even though they are black box separated
from them so to do that we'll have to
exhibit an auxiliary primitive
which is separated from generation yes
to explain the specific primitive so the
specific primitive is
something that would be essentially
simon's oracle
meaning a one-way permutation but where
you have a collision sampler
so like you you have something that
allows you to sample
collisions and it's not exactly a
primitive
so it's a bit all about formulating
exactly what women there but
it's a bit technical but at very high
level this primitive we know does not
black box imply collagen recent hash
function that's simon's result
however if you use say two instances of
this primitive
together like this together with a
one-way function
at a high level it seems to uh imply
a collision horizontal hash function by
using uh the hunger
hundred number the result so the hum gun
lumbar the result says that if you have
two runway functions
uh simultaneously and you have some
strong kind of amplification results
uh like inverting both of them is uh
um happens with probability much smaller
than uh inverting
a single one of them then this implies
collision rates and hash function so we
you can reduce
the conjectures that one-way functions
are black box helpful for causing recent
hash functions
to some conjecture about how um
one-way functions amplify in the
presence of a random oracle
such as simon's oracle that's kind of
the the reduction we have
so the question is i give you so let's
give a simple
formulation of the equation i give you a
one-way function
and a random oracle and the random arc
was sampled independently of the one-way
function
and now you need to invert both can you
prove that inverting both of them
simultaneously your probability of
succeeding
at doing that is even lower than
uh um than the probability of inverting
say just the one-way function
like even smaller than one over
exponential
does that answer your question
what's the solution yeah uh which
implication will it go so i mean like
the last
card and simplification thing if you can
show it then you can sorry i just want
to
make sure that i get the direction yeah
if you can show the last implication you
still don't get much but if you can saw
the last implication on replacing
there so the last conjecture like
one-way functions plus some random
oracle
amplifies like harness amplifies if you
can show that even when the
random oracle is weakened by a collision
finder
then you prove that one-way functions
are black box useless for causing race
and hash functions
but the first step would be to first
prove that you can be helpful yeah jeff
we mean helpful yeah yes
the first step would be to prove that uh
one-way functions amplify
in the presence of a random oracle
without uh
adding collision finders there and e
when this is open
but it looks like a very natural
question
so if you uh hi
just following on the same topic um if
you don't
uh kind of insist on focusing on this
classic question of one-way functions
versus collision resistance and hash
functions do you have any
are there other i mean other examples
that we know that you know already or
would conjecture
that might be easier to prove about the
uh um
something being black box helpful i mean
you know as you said there are many
examples in crypto where we use two
different
uh primitives to build some other
primitive so black box so
the thing so we have say uh
artificial black box helpfulness which
are uninteresting
for example uh the primitive public
encryption plus collision race and hash
function
well each of public encryption and
collision recent hash functions are
black box helpful for building it
but in isolation if some of them is
black box separated
and you can work out this collision
resistance plus
public encryption to get something that
looks like meaningful
um cryptographic primitives like ibe
um with some compact keys uh
so anything that would be some public
encryption but you also want some kind
of
shrinking commitment to to something so
very low rate public
encryption some natural primitives like
that
you can get essentially the same kind of
black box helpfulness
uh like uh cautionary center function
plus public
encryption implies um uh each of them
are helpful
but uh separately there are black box
separated
that's the kind of thing thanks and i'm
curious maybe on the opposite direction
because you mentioned that there are
some black books useless
would it be maybe the most natural or
surprising or i don't know i'm just
curious
well i guess the conjecture of course
for one way functions from key agreement
but in terms of provable results what is
the most
surprising black book useless result
so in a way the other we have are not
surprising because they
ex because they are built upon the
compiling of paradigm
so there are many results in the
literature that have been proven
uh black box separation that have been
present as follow
if you can build uh some primitive from
another one in a black box way then you
can build it build it in the plain model
for example that's the case for if you
can have an efficient construction of a
prg
from a one-way permutation so that makes
only not enough queries to the one-way
permutation
then you have a phd in the plain model
well what we show is that this result
they essentially relativize
so you get blackbox uselessness so if
you can build your prg
using some primitive plus a one way
function
and you don't do not make so many calls
to the one-way permutation
then you don't need the one-way
permutation in the first place
but in a sense it's um say not
completely obvious there are some
technicalities related to uh uh
showing that and proving exactly what we
have
mohammed could tell more about it uh
because it's really related to many
things in his works
uh so it's expected but not completely
obvious
but still expected in a certain sense
but this is like efficiency separation
which is very interesting so basically
you're saying
you cannot you know if you want to have
a very efficient construction
then you know one way functions are
useful useless i guess
uh but if it's not efficiency if it's
just feasibility
is uh something where i don't know you
don't you don't put efficiency
restrictions
well visibility there are a lot of
results of that for
io maybe a couple of weeks ago io would
be still kind of
you know in a different world but i o if
you consider it by now a standard
primitive like we know that many things
cannot give you io with the same
proof uh proof is structured as joffrey
explained you basically compiled them
out from the io construction
and that cons that company got process
also relativizes so
that's the so for feasibility
yeah these all are nothing primitives
they are black boxes so like uh uh
witness encryption and they like they
are black box useless for building
say uh uh approximate and
distinguishability obfuscation yeah yeah
the cat is that it's not exactly always
like approximately correct i o yes
i see
so questions for actually
so maybe just in case there's anybody
else who has questions otherwise you can
even keep going
all right i guess you've got the floor
i'm just not going to clarify
just so maybe yeah just very quickly
clarification for me
so interpretation of black box useless
result means
really if i want to construct it i
shouldn't even consider this primitive
at all it's kind of
uh something like strictly stronger
i'm just trying to see not really it's
it might still help you in a now black
box way like one-way function is
together with io give you public key
cryptography
that's not black box but each of them
alone in a black box way they do not
give you
so you should still kind of think about
it but in our black box
but yeah so if if you think about you
have a bunch of primitives
and you would like to construct to get a
black box construction of another
primitive
then you can you can exclude from your
set all black boxes less perimeters
they won't help you in any black box
construction
so i had a question for one of the other
speakers
uh two for mikito um if mikito is still
there
hi um so
uh just the question was whether there
are any implications of your results
um or versions of them that relate to
the complexity of zero knowledge proofs
because
i mean that was the context in which uh
these kind of
ai primitives were first introduced and
by by ash joshua
so yeah sorry i have
uh so for example you know
if you want to base the hardness of zero
knowledge
on uh np hardness uh the non-triviality
of zero knowledge on np hardness
are there yeah to be honest i
have not considered about the points
they're not supposed to i just only
consider the yeah the starting point is
just np
patterns so
actually i also have a question for you
uh what's your opinion are you
optimistic or pessimistic
in regard to lower like
possibility or new direction yeah
i guess uh yeah the very natural uh
standing point is maybe negative at
present because yeah
so the uh another people class reaction
four
so in the case of uh pseudo-random
generators then we can exclude the
collapse of a hierarchy but
yeah then the existence of the auxiliary
in
pseudonym object one function is
equivalent so
natural thought is yeah even in the case
of uh
object one function we can exclude but
yeah my
in my opinion the positive uh so
in the positive past perspective so the
goal is very
sorry i i have to say very strong
because yeah we can get the np based on
one function but that's why so yeah i
believe indeed i believe
the negative perspective but
i think we should not uh give up such a
positive attitude
at the first glance that's why yeah i
consider the important direction is to
verify the quality of
yeah yeah that's my opinion
nice all right any additional questions
you have
whether a one-way function can be
constructed
in a using a black box reduction from a
worst case hardness
right i mean there are some subtleties i
think a lot of people miss
there are some subtleties here that uh
when you say black box right
you you really mean two things which are
not the same
one is the way the reduction
accesses the primitive right so it
queries
queries and it gets answers back in a
black box way
and the second thing is whether when we
query the adversary
right then are you assuming that this
adversary
is a is an efficient computation or is
the reduction
supposed to work for every choice of
adversary
and most of the separations that we have
in the literature
uh right um when we say black works we
mean both
right so what what we mean is that you
cannot do it with a reduction that
queries the adversary in a black box way
and
also it would work even if the adversary
that is breaking the second primitive
is inefficient right the reason i'm
pointing this out is that there are
there are results out there which are
somewhat similar to what we want to
prove but
weaker right the most famous one is
probably by hirohara from two years ago
but there's also an
organization
which basically show that right i mean
that
right but you can somehow get when we do
have reductions in the literature
which are black boxes but they access
the
adversary in a black box way but they
are able to exploit
the efficiency of the adversary and
for example if you write like for you if
you don't make this distinction these
results
already break these black box separation
so the kind of results that we are
proving using these techniques
right are ruled out by these black box
separations
so we should be there right now we
should be very careful when we say
right i mean things are impossible to
prove in a black box way
but because we don't always mean the
same thing
right like sometimes by only slightly
modifying what we mean
so we make the way so in the paper we
really try to make the
exact st type of black box reductions
extremely clear like we really say if we
have
a blackbox reduction of this type
initially then we can compile out
say the one-way functions and get a
blackbox reduction of this type and
actually there is a loss
we get a weaker kind of lagos reduction
and we also briefly discussed this
notion of class reduction i think this
is what you're talking about
yeah so this notion what that only works
for efficient implementation
of so this will briefly discuss it
actually in the context of
black box helpfulness because uh well i
was hiding
a few things under the roof but this
notion turns actually to
to matter when you look at black box
helpfulness of runway functions
for persian race and hash functions uh
but yeah we try to make the distinction
very clear in the paper
and uh we also acknowledged like these
class reductions as something to look at
yes very interesting problem right and
like so far
right with the exception of hirohara
which is great right we've known these
like
class reductions for like almost 20
years
like 20 years now we haven't been able
to do
anything useful with them right and
somehow right i mean we have these
students
we don't know what to do
yeah i mean we don't even have anything
for separating one-way functions from
key agreement for class reductions
so even even like forgetting about
blackbox uselessness and the likes so
all right any additional questions
comments suggestions
uh future predictions
okay in that case
uh thanks thanks to everyone for for
sticking around
for having the active discussion i think
this has been a lot of fun
and i hope to see you guys around the
rest of the conference